since his election Victory seven weeks
ago Benjamin Netanyahu has been bogged
down in tough negotiations to form a new
Israeli government the right-wing the
could leader was granted a 10-day
extension of his mandate to form a
government which he has needed yeah it's
quite remarkable and a little bit hard
to Fathom he won a decisive election
Victory way back on November the 1st we
knew exactly who the Allies would be in
his Coalition they ran as a block I
guess he would say it's been really hard
they've been driving a really tough
bargain but from the outside it looks
like he projected
bizarre weakness and this is made for a
very complicated process
Netanyahu has formed an alliance with
leaders who until now have been
considered on the fringes of the
political Spectrum like itema Ben gavier
convicted of supporting a terrorist
organization and racist incitement he
will become police minister with
expanded powers to control the force
betzel smotrich will be given
ministerial responsibility for the
illegal settlements in the occupied West
Bank he has long lobbied for their
expansion as well as control over
Palestinian construction there and Aria
Derry who is still serving a suspended
sentence for tax fraud and who needed a
change in the law to allow him to become
Minister the question for many is
whether Netanyahu can keep these
Partners in check I mean what he said is
trust me I'm running the show here but
if you look at the way he's negotiated
his Coalition they've certainly had
they've made their influence felt and
you have to assume that will continue to
be the case amid fears that already
combustible tensions could flare out of
control Palestinians seem to be
expecting the worst with no one
expecting this government to follow any
paths towards peace critics of this
Coalition speculate that some of its
more Hardline members might welcome a
violent Palestinian response to justify
further crackdowns on the occupied West
Bank and Gaza what's clear is with the
unprecedented makeup of this government
Israeli politics are entering new and
Uncharted territory Rob McBride Al
Jazeera West Jerusalem